okay here's our overtime questions we
didn't get to any on the show but this
is what overtime is for Keith Allison
this is for you isn't the last frontier
of racism in this country manifesting
itself in the treatment of Muslims in
America I would say Muslims and atheists
yeah well you know I don't know if it's
the last one I hope it's the last it
would be great if it were the last I got
a feeling that you know from time to
time we just pick a new person to sort
of persecute and scapegoat but even
Muslims are above atheist because they
are people of faith even yes they are
yeah but how many of a theists are being
detained how many of them have been
spied on by the CIA and then in the in
the in the New York well I mean it's
kind of different
you know just didn't I mean there are
circles didn't Muslims didn't either
I'm not that's so that's so smart some
homicidal maniacs did and but I but I
will agreement right in the name of
Islam I mean so what the name of Venice
or what I mean no it isn't so what
because you know cuz look the guy
bearing Brevik in Norway what does it
matter that he slaughtered 70 people you
know he's what wouldn't have mattered in
the name of motivated by distorted form
of Christianity right and I think it's
worth pointing that out I actually don't
and I just Sonia I don't put him in the
there's not one Christian person who I
hold responsible other than and Irving
brevets it has nothing to do with this
religion I agree it has everything to do
with this wrong hate comes from the holy
book it doesn't come from the holy Lord
oh absolutely distortion and I must be
getting a bad translation again well how
often have you read it there I've never
read it in Arabic I'm believing on every
single year since I was 19 years old I
don't know what you guys are talking
about there's nothing in it that says
let me do this well keep pretty pretty
late
III don't think I'm responsible for what
and is predicted in Norway okay I but he
was motivated by a strand within
Christianity that I recognize is
authentically Christian and I don't also
hideous things in the past and I think
that's you can't understand him without
saying that and and that is not a
critter
of all Christians but it is saying look
they're estranged in this religion which
have to be acknowledged recognized and
gotten rid of tonight let me throw in
the feelings I have some reviewers at
some of the fanatics in Israel who have
attacked innocent Arabs and I think in
all three cases Christianity Judaism
Islam I'm sure it's true it's true in
India where you have religious fanatics
hindus and others yeah when people
misuse something you believe in and
invoke it you then do have a
responsibility to be critical of them I
don't think you can simply say a failure
on the part of people to challenge their
co believers and to go with it easy on
them so it's not irrelevant that people
have done in the name of the religion
it's a challenge and it's but it's true
of Islam of Judaism of Christianity of
Hinduism in India also do it's also true
of atheism I mean Stalin and Pol Pot
were atheist they did not challenge
Stalin and Stalinism and apologize for
it and the temptation to apologize for
your own is a serious problem that cuts
across oh yeah I could go on forever
arguing that point but let's just let's
just let's just agree to disagree and
say religions evil and move on one thing
on both side there were still people in
the in Russia who missed on they tend to
be the Orthodox religious people it's
the old traditionalist who nostalgia for
the old days unfortunately comes from
some of the like Solzhenitsyn Emperor
hero do what they did was much more in
common with their religion than with
atheism they were the Emperor was a God
on earth first of all Hitler was not an
agency well there's a lot of controversy
about that he courted the Catholic
Church a lot defeated the Catholic
center boy that's what the Nazis came
from but we're argued about a point we
don't have to argue over look
fundamentalists who believe that they
can kill to make you agree with them are
the problem people of faith I don't
think challenged by people who share
their faith and I agree besides people
who people are just too soft on their
own Muslims of course are not terrorists
but I I found a lot of very reasonable
moderate Muslims who if you say to them
do you think someone if they if they
insult the Prophet
has what it's coming to them if they get
injured they'll say yes well I say no I
know you say no but but there's a lot of
Muslims who say yeah you know if you
insult the Prophet that's on you but let
me just say this when there's one to
burn Korans and actually did you didn't
see any Muslims in the United States
doing anything rowdy or crazy I mean
look it was hurtful but we we observe
the fact that he has a right to his
First Amendment right and and and just
sort of verbally use our free expression
rights to say that it's wrong and a lot
of other people of faith joined but you
know this is another problem right in
America bill you don't get in trouble
for insulting the Prophet you get in
trouble for questioning the puppet
motive what does the panel think of
Mississippi rejecting the personhood
amendment I think it's fantastic
thumbs up I thought that Mississippi one
of the I think I think this one of the
two states I've never been to as a
stand-up comedian I've never been to
Alabama or Mississippi I was always need
to go there now let me shake it I'm
gonna go down to Mississippi
I wasn't Mississippi in the summer 64 I
think both the Mississippi in the Ohio
Board are very important politically
because it is clear that a lot of people
in America aren't happy with the way
things are going the Republicans won in
2010 because of that but the danger for
them which I am glad to see is that they
have been too extreme in that reaction
to it and both in Ohio and Mississippi
what you saw were people in Ohio many of
whom I think may think unions went too
far but the extremism of the reaction
got them similar in Mississippi people
who are opposed to a portion voted
against that and I think this is where
we are you know you see this is a
Republican presidential debates that the
extremism that has taken over the
Republican Party is becoming politically
more of a liability to them than the
than the abuses and with
yeah I agree and but I actually thought
this amendment was kind of really a
positive thing in a way because it
what he did was it unpacked the fact
that there is no moment of conception
that that the line when a human life
comes into being is a very blurry one
and that fertilized eggs in the womb
sometimes attach sometimes don't if you
really believe right the fertilized egg
is a human person a woman's womb is an
appetizer is that concentration camp
murdering millions of human beings now
if it God is the biggest abortionist of
them all
I said I don't think we should be more
moral than God that's that I mean our
standards for human life should not be
higher than God and when you look at
that you see look
nature's complicated now I happen to be
someone who thinks all abortion is wrong
I I believe that the human life is is
really sacred but I also understand that
that human life exists in another
person's body and she has a right to her
own property in her own body and I also
believe that that and as a political
matter but I also believe that it's it's
obviously true that but there is a
moment I mean the old Catholics Aquinas
people back in the Middle Ages they were
smarter they said quickening it's
somewhere in the first trimester we can
say a human being evolves it's only them
again it's the modern extremist
conservative ideology starting with
rotzinger and and john paul ii has taken
this to an insane and let me throw in
one other piece when you said it's one
of the things about this way and one of
the problems people who want to make a
portion criminal have is how do you
avoid it if you believe that prosecuting
the woman who's consented to have an
abortion if you believe that abortion is
taking it's in life then a woman who
goes voluntarily to have an abortion is
as guilty as a mother who brings her
three-year-old to a football coach in
Pennsylvania and the the the issue then
becomes for them how do they deal with
that they avoid it but the Mississippi
issue brought that out it under that
stat under that constitutional amendment
the women would have been criminals and
this is a great merit in a way of this
extremist stuff that it out the fact
that this argument doesn't really
in the end you take it to its logical
extreme you have to start one a bright
but and that's also why those elections
are so significant for 2012 well
Democrats have trouble trying to say
everything is wonderful and I you know
the slogan things would have been worse
without us it's never anything that's
gonna bumper sticker but on the other
hand what the response is wait a minute
things may be tough but these people are
nuts that's a better world
ya know the great irony Barney point out
is they've dug row v Wade is the best
advantage Republicans ever got because
it protects them from themselves if they
if they were out in every state passing
these kinds of incredible laws they
would be hated as a political party roe
v-- wade protected him from themselves
you're so smart
yeah but always always have to say I
don't think Obama's gonna win on these
people are crazy I mean he has and I
hate to say this but he's been a coward
on a couple of fundamental issues he has
no policy or proposal for tax reform
everybody acknowledges this tax code is
a [ __ ] night unlike which Payne who
did well I'm sorry but but he's a poet
you know he well buddy no president has
done that but I gotta go
thank you very much everybody I
appreciate you in here
thank you